Epson competitions for
permanent employees of the
institutions of the European Union what does
it mean is personal is the acronym for
giorpião
Selection Office the european
personnel selection service is the service that
allows the different
european institutions such as
the european commission the european parliament the council  from the European
Union to recruit officials
to join their teams this year we are going to
have two competitions from May that
I personally find very interesting
the first will be for economists and the
second for administrators in the field
of intellectual property and they may
be thinking in the field of
intellectual property so where to
work in education Spain at the
Institute of the European Union that
deals with intellectual property issues
the economists competition is
an av6 competition What does this
mean AD means administrators 6
is a category since the
categories for  admins go from
ad-5 which is c  entry category up to
ad12 which is the last category for
administrators There are others below but they
are categories that apply to
management positions Well B6 means that you
are asking for some
professional experience but not much What does
this mean in practice  I would say between
three to five years of
professional experience I still don't have the
formal description of this competition for May but
I can tell you that it will be more or less
ah these two goals that will be
used for this competition for
economists
the competition for administrators in the
field of intellectual property  it will
also be a B6 competition so
once again it requires some
professional experience but not a lot of
professional experience for 2023 I would also like to
highlight something very important since
the great entry generalist competition has not happened since 2019
and thus an av5 competition
once again AD  administrator 5 the
entry category for administrators in
institutions  European Union This is a
contest that I hope will have many
Portuguese candidates and many
well-prepared candidates that allows
a very wide variety of profiles to
apply to be an employee of
the European institutions what do I
mean by a wide variety of
profiles I'm talking about people who have
studied law
international relations engineering medicine
sociology any and all areas that
can be studied at
university level are areas considered
for this competition it is therefore a
very important opportunity for
anyone interested in working for the
european union as it is  let's
say a competition really open until
then more news on the Epson website about
other competitions that will be published in
2023 but these three
administrator economists in the field of
intellectual property and the great
generalist ad5 competitions are
really worth it